[Music]
yesterday is a canceled check and
tomorrow is an IOU all you have is the
moment what do you choose to do with
your moment
and I just started Living that it was it
was that that started resonating with me
I have the moment I am in complete and
total control over my seconds now I can
be as happy as I choose to be and that
is where I stay empowering to have
agency it's wonderful this is your time
yeah this is nobody else's moment but
yours what are you gonna think how you
gonna feel you're going to laugh you're
gonna cry what are you gonna do with
this moment this now I don't wallow in
yesterday
and I really too worried about how I'm
gonna pay the rent tomorrow
because I got now yeah